I am live we are live flashpoint Ibaka
Rossi flashpoint YouTube gaming zone
[Laughter]
challenge master mommy no ID but I'm
doing good man doing pretty good so yeah
get some family coming in town today so
get a little housecleaning and stuff to
do looking at next week's reset going
like holy moly there's a lot going on
and yeah and just all um thank you for
everybody just all the love out there
recently so channel kind of keeps going
YouTube felt like saying hey in a crazy
way that I'm still insanely humble did
not travel they chose me by but overall
it's been a good week how you don't know
week but um other than that has been
pretty good came back from Jim had found
me park spot it was weird get home but I
had to run in got a lot to talk about as
far as the week man he's been good and
uh you know hit my mouth stone very
appreciative and just just trying to
grow this thing man and it's good to see
you know good people you know saying
like myself like ebon says you know
sticking with it and and being
recognized and that's that's a content
creator so you want right that you just
want you know people to respect to work
and when I seen that for you man I was
like my boys out did it and they paid
attention they watch the video yeah I
was like okay font is here he's here and
it's good to see so salute you my
flashpoint brethren well thank you sir
very much yeah it's it's been kind of
crazy but Justin to the lamb like tell
me how does
I don't you get it goes with it that's
what I like doing it I'm glad if we get
more people that are finding videos
finding them like helping them do the
solo content that's why I make the
guides and the things that I do is to
help it inform and guide you along the
way as calm and collected as possible so
I'm never gonna be able to one of the
big animated like Wow like in the moment
of doing the night fall I might have
some weird little like clips that come
out here and there but I mean and that's
why I was like I may not be the biggest
but I mean I'm definitely humbled very
much at what's happened so thank you
guys for all the recent support and just
keep it going by the way for all you
guys if you do watch this go look at
iron Lords podcast on YouTube go right
over there and subscribe to their
channel there I want to see them double
let's double their subscribers guys
let's get them a whole bunch so it means
a lot coming come on if you guys want a
good entertaining video gaming podcast
with some awesome interviews good people
I mean you'll go on there and they get
it's a long-form podcast here you get
some of those interviews into deep dives
that's not like hey what do you think
about this game how is this developing
to be like what was your gaming history
like were you playing Super Nintendo
when you were a little like little you
know a little kid on the couch like
those are little things that make
especially someone more mature like me
when I go back and think about gaming I
was like Oh hit me right in the fields
talking about like you know yes like
first system was like that was me so no
go check out the iron Lords podcast guys
it is good good stuff gives you
definitely something to I mean yeah if
you got a long commute or anything like
that take a couple days easier commute
it's a good one so definitely spend some
time on so and those guys have you know
it's genuine how much fun they have
because sometimes they're laughing their
butts off
but yeah what's so are you daunted by
time I'm not even gonna say what Tuesday
has yet but are you Tuesday just like
holy bike too much like we're almost
yeah cuz you know what is I'm surprised
we'll get into the twelve I'm definitely
surprised how they combine things
so yeah it was just like okay so we know
you know lost is coming and I didn't
think it was just like sneak banner on
us like that why I was like okay you
know we'll get into it but um yeah it's
very much overwhelming it's a lot but in
a good way I mean we we asked for
content he asked for things to do you
know that was one of the main quips and
now to see this just boom boom boom boom
boom it's always something and then like
you say well we got the third week of
the the throne or whatever so um yeah
it's a ton it is a ton to do but again
if your destiny fan you live for this
but you just sleep-deprived
that's all yeah pretty much like
honestly I'm not gonna be able to fit
everything in yeah so it's like you
gotta prioritize now right you gotta
kind of like you know which way is
you're gonna go you know so what what
are you leaning towards prioritize it uh
well it depends on if I can I've got
family in town so there's no way that I
can probably burn through my hunter fast
enough to really make that grind as a
like Bible so I think that one's gonna
have to wait a week like tightening and
warlock are both correct 580 so I'm
getting up there so I mean shattered
Thrones an important one because for one
I haven't done it - I want to see if
that solo is viable or if I really
mostly just need to be 600 last time I
went in there so much lower so much more
well esoteric with is he went in there
right so how many six yeah he's ready
yeah do a hundred thousand night foam
like yeah when I'm 611 forty Blake sixty
points then I'll consider a 60 point
yeah grab a hundred thousand but don't
come later but yeah shadow Ted also
beast mode yeah so I was like I'm torn
because I know iron banner is there the
grinds are a little bit slower which
we'll get to not slower actually quicker
they're a little less and length and
then so that's some powerful gear like
to fill gaps and stuff which is nice but
I think for me I've got to go like
shattered thrown festival of lost an
iron banner maybe last on a
like shatterdome and because mostly
because depending on how the forest is
set up and we'll get to that in a little
bit will be if you need a group or Sol
LeWitt or whatever and I'm sure you can
run it both ways in how important it is
to get a certain like distance into that
thing apparently is if I'm gonna need to
run it on like Tuesday with my couple
friends that I know I do or if I can
solo that stuff later so just gonna
connect to see where the solo and the
team priorities gonna fall okay I think
my ordered might really have a I'm such
a grind with crucible cuz the only thing
I've been consistently playing is on
quick play about a lot of valor crucible
I'm doing so good on my rechak screen
I'm grind I'm like maybe you know two
steps from the end now I gotta get a
certain amount of precision kills with
pulses and I got like one of these god
roll-on pulses right now the guy was
like a god roll go figure and I gotta
buy guns which I haven't used but all my
guns that one's killing me Mary said
like you seem to get the god roll so
yeah he's a god roll oh yeah melee said
yeah he's not is dead you know how long
that lasts
what that just set in his inventory is
it like a rotating inventory / reset
like is that God roll bygones that the
drifter has mmm does that ever change
that's a good question I don't know I
was thinking of the reset when you
actually reset your infamy everyone
seems to get like the god roll bygones
that's what I'm talking about
or maybe bad omens because he's in
inventory it's currently sitting there
so I want to know if that changes I'm
like do I have to rush to get know if
his has been there since start mostly
alcohol that's gonna be going on like
weekly rotation or anything reach in for
me with rank twelve kill clip full auto
disability yeah yeah but I've seen some
damn good buy guns or somebody I saw
that was like oh I want it I want it I'm
getting shot in the cruiser by a lot
that in loon is how good lord
oh my lord
without it you better beasts you better
be safe man it's not safe out here
be careful did you get Lunas how that's
my question I'm not even I'll just like
I just competitive is not in a place
mode wise where I like so I don't have
that incentives and I got to run around
with hand cannons for that length of
time
like I'm more of a pulse guy right now I
mean the post meta is really strong to
me even though Laura how it was like
showing to be the dominant weapon but
hey those guys got that you know they
did the grind got salute them god bless
them I want my reg ex I'm still in my
like GT making over finished it and I
want that reg Rick's that's the gun I
want so bad and I'm a post guy and they
said
Shantanu um cross he was it's got a DVD
and I that's what I want to see I want
to really put it through its paces to
see what type of role I get and it's all
about rhetorics right now I'm about I'm
on step 5 of 7 and I've already got like
2 or 3 arm prestigious already
oh I know I know it's like I have not so
yeah yeah and last thing you know why
banners gonna be my priority most likely
is because even salad deviled eggs well
first of all we can but yeah Ironman
I'll give you extra incentive person
power supply well how are you now by the
way I haven't even asked no power level
or power level I've been it's been a
slow Creek for me oh I think I'm like a
little oh I'm like maybe 575 close to
580 oh yeah I'm low man but where I'm at
I mean it's not low I hit like 583
something like that so now I have 580 -
shout the citizen in chat all them dudes
at 600 they run around they sleep videos
making content we got to work they just
play exactly
hey now how you working all these hours
and doing all these podcasts videos I
guess you salute to the team a salute to
class
well we go well yeah no one in the world
of bungee so Bungie feels like throw in
the world at us this week so we're gonna
have to try and jump into that first we
got festival of the Lost now for those
of you guys that haven't been around
this is basically their Halloween event
Monday of course put it seemed into the
world of destiny which is cool it's not
just a Halloween slap it slap like a
pumpkin in the tower something like that
actually have a seat back chill I have
some lore behind and stuff like that
which is always cool that's one of those
things that like maybe it may have been
an underwhelming event for some of this
stuff but they tend to put yeah they're
gonna be like you know normal holidays
normal themed stuff like that they put a
destiny spin they spend a little extra
time and they put a destiny spin to make
these things actually fit into the world
of destiny which is cool so shout out to
those guys but a festival Lost is for
Guardians death is usually a temporary
condition no more dangerous than the
Splinter on a forgotten and forgotten
just as quickly even after a villain
want a first brought the city's
traditions to the tower with festival
lost it was less a time for remembrance
and more of a time of irreverent
celebration last year's changed
everything the red Legion res this
raised the city countless guardians were
lost
despite victories on Mercury and Mars
morale in the towers low after the fall
of a legend cayde-6
this years and this year death has not
passed us by it has come to stay so
little little somber there it's been an
interesting year so we have forsaken now
which has been amazing for all of us
those of you guys who powered through in
the world of destiny to year 1 kind of
feel like we've kind of broken out of
our shell and now we actually get a
full-size game to play which is fun but
we got a lot to do so Festival loss
usually always has like masks and they
decorate up the tower and there's some
cool stuff involved a little bit more to
this one which if you've got wheat I'm
like I want to see if they actually
follow through with this one so first
off the event is gonna be run by Amanda
Holliday she's the gonna be the woman
hold no she's gonna get used that's
great yeah so she's just been holding
down those low green and blue sparrows
and ships for you forever
the kindergarten Ian's basically just
finally got a home so kind of late
there's that no one has heard from evil
Levante since the city bell right Amanda
holiday has stepped in to help raise
everyone's spirits so what do you think
like Ava Eva's not coming back I mean I
know we got ever verse so he's like
she's kind of in a different spot do you
think this is fading for Amanda do you
think it's like just kind of weird a
little weird that she's doing it I'll be
honest um you know I thought that I hope
I was hoping that we'd get more clarity
with you know the Levante situation you
will about it
so um you know but are they confer
remain ask your question I have they
confirmed she's dead I thought she
confirmed just missing no I mean they
just said no one's heard from her so
yeah they've confirmed other deaths but
yeah she just she stepped out she's
alright so she stepped out we gotta find
her whatever kind of deal okay cool um
yeah I just gotta I just want to see you
know how to eat how am I like Amanda has
a character I just want to see how it
kind of works I've never really
associated her with you know she's like
hey Guardian you know she's like ships
and flying and mechanic and like you
know I mean like I don't get her as the
let's do something great for the city
doing Greece not decorating things yeah
exactly
perfect perfect analogy so I'm like
alright look but at the end of the day
they needed to do something with her so
I'm gonna let this slide she needs she's
completely useless for any og and even
as a as a kindergarten I wasn't running
that chaperone quest that's it oh that's
what the only time I've used her I think
I did when um what was it on Mars when
you got all the things and you go to her
and you get your Sparrow you give that
one from her but yeah it's like minimal
stuff and honestly like you want to give
her a little purpose like somebody do a
side project for a day your figure out
how to put it in so I can reroll my damn
Sparrow rolls yes let me let me have my
instant loading or let me you know pay a
little extra
let me grind on a quest I could have the
fast loading and maybe reload my guns or
the fast loading
and maybe less time just let me work on
some just let me add a little extra let
me get that little like bonus to my
sparrow because yeah you get an exotic
and it's got the wrong roll and well be
like well your even though one of my
buddies actually did say I think he got
the you got the Dreaming city's marrow
which is actually pretty cool looking
but he didn't get a good roll on it but
it was like can you just blood out of
your collection now and see if you can
get a different role and I think you can
so in it I think you could actually pay
to get one out of there now which is
good but aliso may be less of a benefit
now but generally yeah she's she needs
something to do yeah and I think it's
exasperated by the fact that we have
since destiny to launch we also have not
had Sparrow racing and so but she always
had a big role with that you know me so
it really just made her you know very
now you just chose to be like the
experice may not still be coming anytime
soon
so thought that was interesting because
usually what her but we going in to get
our helmets we get stuff you get your
bow knees from her you're doing all that
stuff so yeah so it's good to see she's
getting some love and the tower is
obviously gonna get a makeover as you
guys can see we've got a little bit here
with Tower decor so we've got the little
candles they're bringing back those
little purple ones are gonna be
everywhere we've got a little hanging in
Graham lanterns and stuff like that so
under the tree who is that
so that's weird because well we know one
person they mentioned has a face here
but this doesn't quite look right who is
that oh I know who he is yeah that's our
guy that is one of my most hated NPC's
in Destiny's history that is master eyes
or Eve's well I can't pronounce it oh I
don't know this pictures got hair on it
master I was appalled she's bored the
one I'm talking about that picture that
I saw yeah yeah what's actually in the
middle that's I don't know I'm told my
the Volga Volga is definitely even I
couldn't stand him so I am I can't wait
to find out the situation and thank the
person who put this man down
why do you hate this more pies listen I
do actually go back to one of our old
IOPS and we just only doing destiny
content and we did a segment it was cool
I want to do with you at some point we
did a segment called favorite and worst
NPCs your favorite embassies and your
most hated NPCs but I had everyone laugh
they're like why do you hate him so much
I said listen when you go to the reef
you had farik's back in the d1 right yet
barracks you had Petra you had brother
Vance when he was cool before he became
like Paris I was his favorite bat like
you know he just halt when I go for the
south he was a real cool biblical do you
go go to ditch trials and Osiris gear it
was cool then you walk pass master eyes
and I vaguely remember actually I think
I definitely remember when used to have
House banners or anything yet exchanged
with this guy for whatever reason it
would never equate to the same amount
giving back that what Raul would give
you and I'm like am i buggin out here
like I was going to be a bright how come
when I go to the reef [ __ ] talk like I'm
not getting all the credit for my house
banners and all the stuff that I'm
turning in and then like yeah it might
be a glitch or something so I just
attributed to the character I didn't
like the character it was like well he's
very arrogant like I'm talking to this
and so I am so glad someone put him down
you know I wanna think that the animal
or the Guardian whoever did it thank you
for ridding the bane of my existence
I would bash it at if it is bad that
it's funny I tell a child if you here at
master ives funeral ignore this guy over
here on the other side is a unkind man
and not an honored guardian he has been
dishonored himself seriously like I mean
it's so funny though because I saw
people in Twitter on the other complete
flip side of this going like oh how you
gonna take my master I was like that's
why that's why you saying this is just
like mauling me leg
I remember him vividly one way or
another just go to him see I lived in
the reef ice to play trials so for me
I'm like you would start to sit in a
chase glimmer exchange was a ripoff
people knew something was up with that
guy that guy's a shyster I'm telling you
it was always exchange Lucy Bravo
he would he would give you the right
extra he have snarky comment but he give
you the right exchange this guy oh man I
knew it was something wrong something's
going on
but yeah shout at the citizen to the
chat but he he completely treats me
remembrance well somebody took care of
him so that will be part of this but got
a couple different activities with
festival loss which will be cool now I
honestly am really intrigued by one of
these the most we'll get to in a second
just because we're kind of scrolling
through so we'll have new triumphs which
will be good a little more stuff to earn
that and do our little triumphs for some
people when they it wouldn't Bungie send
out that hey what's your triumph score
right now they're like fifty thousand
I'm like I'm just sitting out here with
like 25 you're like John Travolta with
me like I am apparently slacking so some
people are playing like crazy yeah so
you get more triumph hole he'll have
daily bounties that award fragmented
souls these items can be used to
purchase festival lost mast as well as
the horror story legendary auto rifle
mm-hm
so actually got an auto rifle coming
from one of these events aid events
specific gun how long has it been asking
for that a long time oh it's crimson
doubles whether it's and that would've
been the time to bring the Crimson in by
the way yes but I mean the fact that we
actually have one gun we're gonna have
your set of armor that's probably there
and the mask we actually have an auto
rifle from an event I can't leave this
otherwise I just like that it's an
option yes definitely like gear some to
associated with an event like unique
here so you remember it's pretty cool
pretty cool yeah so no idea if it's
gonna be good or bad I'm sure tomorrow
Hamlisch is gonna have some data mined
version of it I always like digging deep
into Bungie servers or some probably
he's a beast
now this this is what I'm waiting for
right here all right right
hey this year just lost brings more than
just masks because that's usually what
kind of vessel loss has been and that's
why it's one of the things that hasn't
really set that well because it hasn't
been a major deal mm-hmm so they finally
are doing something with a very very
unusual for a limited time all players
of Destiny 2 are invited to the haunted
forest and when they set 4 is the first
time I heard that anywhere is like
please tell me they're going to the
infinite forest and they are tasked with
clearing out its ghouls and demons which
are spooked up by a storm you'll have 15
minutes to dive as deep as you can into
the haunted forest and clear out the
nightmares lying in wait be wary the
deeper you go the more difficult your
job will become honestly I've been
waiting this is what they should
literally have the infinite force be all
the time why is it not just part of you
mercury would not suck nearly as much as
this little ring of idiocy mm-hmm sorry
Bunch if you're listening this cuz I
know you guys still made content don't
mean it's laugh at that hard but just
it's underutilized like it's in a couple
adventures it's in the couple strikes
and this is finally a reason to go in
there and just run deep in there now
they say you do not have to have any
expansion for this you'll literally be
able to load into the infinite forest
separately you're not gonna have to have
Mercury's expansion gotcha
um so that's a good thing and then the
other piece behind it is just the fact
that this is how far can you go this is
like how far can you push into a horde
note in 15 minutes yes I love that
absolutely love that that's gonna be
cool so I like the lighting effects on
it kinda has that darker tone mm-hmm I
wonder if things are gonna like creep up
next you and be like hey there's a
knight oh the crap lake forest you know
anyway I'm very curious like the lore
wise because this is clearly the
infinite for it so I want to know if
like this is me as an osiris family Oh
like maybe a tea Lord mention of Y you
know say like was because this is
technically his round this is where
Osiris is like yeah so you
very curious like law wise what they
they say about that so yeah I mean
listen it's it's a it's an asset that
was underutilized you know it was a cool
asset in theory it just wasn't used I
felt enough or you know it can be
enhanced even to be better and this
sounds cool going deeper you know more
challenging bosses more things this
sounds cool so I'm with it I'm very
curious about and like I said they've
never really done anything like you said
outside of masks for festival laws so
now we have this mystery you know a
couple things going on actually sounds
pretty cool that like I go were the
event yeah so I mean this is probably
one of those things like hustle loss is
gonna go away and everybody's be gonna
be like 10 hey you got any more of that
haunted forest out there see I'm
guessing if it's done well or if it's
just a fun activity to do the day
actually try and bring this thing back
so that honestly that's probably has the
needy most intrigued besides the last
week quest of course but I think this
will be cool to go on with a fireteam
course there as much as you can I don't
know if they'll they probably won't slap
scoring on this thing but I'm sure
there's like certain like landmarks and
stuff that you're gonna have to get to
and like esoterics gonna find the end of
the map all on his own well quick
question for bud said he's a dog who's
new oh he says so who is everyone's
favorite character mine is Shaq so
pretty much I was gonna ask you this
because when we did that segment on our
old ILP like new favorite NPCs and you
know hate it so you're know whom I hated
your favorite NPC's in two of your hated
NPCs oh I'm probably not even gonna
remember all the right names from d1
generalization witty was the name I did
like and especially is probably mostly
because of the rise of our and expansion
was Saladin okay I was cool that was
cool he was just like dude I'm a beast I
got my back Serhant or whatever was but
was like he's just a monster man
the original as well Jackson Jackson I
feel like I don't know if he's top cuz I
mean for me Cade was always up there but
obviously he stepped down now
Shaq's in crucible is sometimes just
crazy like I just love those little
comments alone seriously just like
there's no what you can't enjoy him
pardon me has a weird soft spot for Eris
just because she is the the oddball out
in all this stuff she's like well she's
always sitting under the stairs she's
like the Harry Potter like apartment
under the stairs type thing so she
didn't ever get a great great place to
land one's mine I hated me for a whole
pissed me off for a long time so because
I didn't spend as much time with I was
taking you guys offer whoo oh yeah
somebody said it the other day is like
screw or hole oh here's an exotic no
it's a green yeah I'm sorry that's the
stuff that I remember from him so yeah
and the speaker yeah he was just useless
right there yeah yes like granted he had
one of the absolute best lines in the
destiny one campaign I've ever seen
anybody throw homeless babe at Gaulle
when he's like why don't you just go die
oh yeah laid it down so I mean I have to
give a little bit of problems for that
one mostly just kind of he had no
purpose so he was just over there if you
had to go over there you go to that far
in the tower a little bit either way but
it just depends on what I was working on
really half the time for me now I would
say you know Osiris always mean I'm a
woman you know that's just facts they
just got to redo his story correctly but
um let me see
surprised you know who I absolutely like
burst into laughter sexes on heaven
should be honest but I might happen
he's a sure beer ashley is funniest most
bitter and PC I enjoy it impossible come
on no like honestly I'm totally blanking
on one Ava was just thinking Mort our
failsafe
and the fact that you can actually tweak
her into the raid knows like I've got to
hear that definitely like I say got a
shout out ashes just hilarious it he
hates everything but everybody like do
you think Civ Allah would actually think
about this or or he just go in there and
swing a sword and blow up the entire
universe of course he would like in my
channel you're a sure music he's like
you can't you happy when you do any pair
of median strikes oh my god knows
hilarious I want you to rip its arm off
all the bitterest MPC the entire destiny
so you're creative shacks Gallo says
Cyrus isn't giving some sad fanboy and
I've come to after I've changed my tune
on executive it Hadiya changed my time
yeah because they they shaders are so
dancin like I don't care if you have
quality gear or morals or anything just
do you like the morals you got the good
good you got the nice side of the towel
honestly like like like it's got one
that for me not as much hated but I got
a I got a shot him out two-for-one that
I could kind of care less about hero
she's like an impersonation of Caden it
always rubbed me wrong and I was like
dude no like uh you don't mm-hmm shout
out to Jeff Roma Jacek eight-six and FWC
oh you like lucky me like CVD love her
voice actor hate it dead or but yeah I
don't like the emo kid was his face from
mom dead oh I know who the actor is also
dead orbit yeah he's cool he's there was
in a lot of like almost Russian villain
roles yeah yeah absolutely he said
anyone get chills when I character spoke
for the first now one of the most hated
non-speaking people cuz the ghost is
like and even ki look like this is one
of those points where bungees like I
don't know if they have decided not to
they have a few lines they have eight
words they finally got a couple but it's
just like up still always the stroke the
silent type or whatever I'm
yes oh yeah listen it was it was a
monumental step for the even throw that
back in you know let's see how much they
advance on our character speaking again
but uh I was actually pushing that
forward we gotta push it I was surprised
that they even did it to be honest so
like wow they really are listening
because I didn't think they would ever
revert back to that so yeah you got some
interesting ones you got some good ones
I like to like your choices yeah so I'm
sorry tangent aside we're back to the
possible loss but yeah I mean yeah
they've always got some good characters
in there that had some some have had
some long history so it's been kind of
cool but yeah infinite forests into the
haunted forest like kind of a horde
event 15-minute run probably go back to
the tower and do it over and over again
see how you do
I'm hoping it's just gonna be a really
cool thing so yeah crossing my fingers
on that one I'm in this picture right
here just the way the lighting looks on
it you've got this that night looks to
be one of the bigger ones that you don't
really want to take off I can't tell
this a normal night or want to like the
big nice that you see in like the
ascendant challenges that dad almost
looks escalation protocol level yeah
little big boys yep like a big boy down
there so yeah it's gonna be it looks
like the challenges are really gonna
ramp up the deeper you get and yeah it's
I'm excited a new low mode a new little
activity I didn't expect any of this
Professor loss to be honest so you can
jump jump in into the dark as a solo
player with a premade fire team or
through matchmaking to join up a
Guardians in the fight I like how they
give all the options nice you know the
fire team solo mm-hmm this is actually
one of those things I'm curious about
and this is one thing they really really
should do go for it how are you gonna
jump in with matchmaking or solo how's
it gonna pick because they have never
actually had either matchmaking or solo
because either you do a nightfall and
you have to have people with you yes and
you go for it that's a good point
pick to run by yourself yes that's a
good point unless having solo queue for
this give me a solo queue for
yeah yep beautiful yes I am banner you
know I mean like oh my god an iron
banner needs it more than quick boiling
crucible now yeah I bet definitely needs
it now so I'm with you in its that's
that that's a good catchy because that's
the first time I've ever seen destiny
advertising activity and say you have
the option to join as a solo player so
Wow
interesting yeah that was one of those
little pieces I noticed I'm like I want
to know how they do that because they
have the slits like a switch for you
just say infinite forest or haunted
forest so long of course I'm gonna be
like woah woah woah
alright let's see this in a couple other
places and that'll be happy man
yes are joining in to chat thank you
guys for coming in Long Point always
never sword the one you get to destiny
fanatics like us to do big things are
gonna happen conversation this right
here this is the one with eyes this is
the one and yeah this is the one looks
like it's in front of the tree so that's
why the graphic above my picture with
hair because he loved straight up bald
that's the ball gaps - gasps that's the
blade yes respects the killer the most
players of forsaken have already won
justice for cayde-6 but near the
conclusion of festival loss they'll be
called once again to avenge our fallen
friend for some apparently master ives
has been struck down maybe someone
wanted to settle an old score maybe it
was Cognito who jumped into the servers
or and lost their temper when receiving
the edge transit see this is one of
those points honestly cuz I've actually
had some comments lately they've been
like so many edge trains it's and I'm
just like yeah because I think I in my
video like I must have opened my
inventory and been like oh just quick
and through quickly looking at something
it was like five or six in my heavy slot
I'm like just 2 min I have 30 I just
need to pare them down to like your Wow
it's kind of a joke at this point to be
like how
he can actually accumulate yeah it's
ridiculous take out they supposed to be
addressing that with that patch heavy
the heavies jumping in that slot anyway
yeah we need a few more options just in
general what ever built quick quick
sidebar mom the real even though I'm
joking with master Yves and stuff the
real thing from what I understand is
that the voice actor that played him I'm
sorry the voice actor that played him is
the voice actor that currently plays
devran Kay right I have heard that yes
so it's literally the same inflection
the same voice so that's why so pretty
much you know Devin is not going
anywhere right now
he's pretty much liked and um yeah I
think that's another reason why we're
seeing this kind of stuff as well as far
as that character as well a little more
way to kill a character and preserve a
voice actor from doing two things so
exactly whatever provoked the the
wrongdoing justice must be served the
pursuit of Master Ives killers killers
by the way so that's a plural I didn't
catch that the first read will take
place through a quest line which adds an
additional powerful roared so another
thing to do the hunt begins on Tuesday
the 30th now festival loss is gonna be
three weeks long starts on the sixteenth
goes through what does it november
second hurt yes no november number six
yep so it actually goes for three weeks
actually like that we've got three full
weeks so you're out of town you miss
something you know right you got plenty
of time to play this event and get
hopefully most of the stuff you're going
for exactly exactly
don't want to get excuse oh I didn't
have time it was this week three weeks
three weeks yeah you ain't playing this
is why I like shattered throne is gonna
be a priority for me then I don't know I
gotta jump in and see with this whole
like planted things about cuz that's
some kind of a waiting on for a while
yeah shadow I just thought about it
though shadow troll might be a thing for
me too because did you see Tess
Everett's
latest package does she selling with the
bow ornament you know that ornament we
Shinda you i okay look like already what
I thought no it's actually like just
plain like white or gray or whatever
dude when I saw it at Queen little
purple
Oshin I was okay I might be incentivize
now to get that down that's nice that's
nice but anyway nope you're good
so Festival loss of course will have its
cosmetic rewards as well it's gonna be a
ephemeral Engram so those are gonna work
along the side of your steadfast and
grams so you're gonna get double which
is always cool and then you may also
purchase the engrams in case you you
know want to just blow through some
money and get some extra ones
one thing they did saying I think I've
heard it out there and Twitter I do
believe this is gonna work as a
checklist so if you're going through
working on anything specific and you
play this a decent amount you will be
start able to widdle things off of that
list so you don't get duplicates now I
could be making that up but I'm pretty
sure I saw it on Twitter or somebody out
there did finally post that so I think
it is gonna be you know checklist knock
that stuff up so you know if I get the
ship on the Left which looks crazy
awesome by the way yes if I get that one
then I'm not gonna get a duplicate of
that until I have hopefully everything
else so ship on the left and gotta get
the cat ghosts I'm not even a cat person
it's just I like how literally they like
tape to the ears on there so it looks
like those are is cool somebody in the
somebody said about this when I forget
who it was on Twitter and was like am I
looking at a Gundam in the middle what
is going on with the big white sparrow
that looks Ken I know it's like almost
like like a Gundam like being raised up
like on the world so yeah they
definitely put some nice art into these
I like that this is he like this one
over here I don't know why for me like
that somebody's like please let that be
Steven not just vanes please let that be
see they're not just as a good point I
didn't think about you can see yeah
I was like it doesn't quite looks evil
like though it does actually look veiny
and not quite but for me this one looks
ten times cooler than this one this one
has like purple stuff on it and this one
I don't know my just looks cooler and
maybe it's just cuz I like the shape of
the ship more because this looks like
the fighter jet and this just looks like
a flying box but
go get some chips what cooler than
others I just got the aid this week
actually I'm in my weekly reset I hadn't
three of the what are they the prismatic
facets yes and I go to open the
prismatic matrix and there's four things
I don't have me exotic catch ship the
upper own ornament and two other pieces
so I was like alright well spend two of
them in here and see what I get
exotic exotic I'm like alright well I
guess I'm done so I was like two for two
is like I'm out nice catch is cool it
definitely looks funny but these I was
these are some of the ones just because
they stand out the most or some of the
ones I want yes and this is also the
point where I wish you could reroll
ghosts as well yeah is like I might get
one of these but I will never use it if
it's rolls suck mm-hmm so we'll see how
it goes but you'll be able to earn
double engrams which is cool you'll be
able to buy some if you really just
don't have that much time to play and we
also have some emotes yes so somebody on
a guitar solo just absolutely killing it
but over here just crazy dance man just
absolute I love so many dances because
they get into it so much they cost so it
was like Jackson's like two years ago
they're like the longest emotes every I
love it I love ATO repeat so you can
leave the character or just answer my
crazy yeah I want to be there when they
when they motion cap one of these things
really what I just watch them that's
done a lot of it which I found out on
you know I'm a podcast Widow we had a
shout-out to her Rick Hogue from holding
law a lot of these things bandit just
copy database away you know say like you
know from certain artists and stuff like
that for pop culture stuff like that but
it's funny it's funny I I think it's
interesting not able to get away with it
we discussed that and though it's
definitely something that's going to
there's a mocking is you know we all buy
this stuff it anytime I go to the tower
there's people doing these dances with
their Guardians
oh well have you been out in the world
and see people doing the floss from
fortnight which is so that's most of
what we have for festival I think that
pretty well covers it so let's jump over
to the club which starts with that
mm-hmm oh this we get bungee at here
Festival on October 16th to do member
six you got masks so of course old runs
gonna be in there I love how they have a
chicken mask the kernel the kernel is in
the house
curd or what is the middle one by the
way who is this like steampunky dude
yeah I don't it looks just like trying
to figure it out
that's a good question like hmm I don't
know if it's a new one or if it's just
kind of a steampunk look but it's a
weird one it's a weird one I don't know
what's that wonder if like the mask
maybe one thing which may be like kind
of robotic yeah but I think this is
actually probably the hunter cape
because yeah that's a hundred K but I
don't even notice that at first but I've
said that's a whole like old school
which wizard what about what about that
whole quest with um the whole thing with
drifter and shag was a chin mal Fuhrer
and all these guys wasn't the one was
the one that got killed I'm not my
Laura's off right now so Mike I'm asking
like that whole story between the last
word and the thorn all right and the guy
that killed the thorn guy which was you
know in that because they have a whole
thing on this and the Lord if you go
into the ascendant plane you'll see his
outline of his body I just want to
confirm maybe in your chat might know
that guy that got killed
was he a hunter and maybe could because
remember this is honoring dead Guardians
we know Aldrin bit the bucket no said I
don't know why the colonel is up there
but whatever what the colonel was still
in the tablet whatever in the forefront
it looks like an older character right
it looks based on what we see
on this picture in this image yeah
somebody much that was saying it might
just be the hunter armor like literally
the mask okay it might just be the helm
for the gear you might be able to get
from this event which definitely has
kind of unique look like steampunk
Halloween going crazy the cloak
obviously is but it may just be a you
know literally the helm for that
character it just fits in kind of being
creepy
but actually one of the things I was
wondering about on this as well because
power level being a thing that matters
for sure there's no way the haunted four
I kind of wonder what okay now I have
multiple questions I have someone let's
go okay first are you gonna have to put
the mask and replace your and everything
that was a problem well as a festival to
loss you would lose your light now
London around with these masks yeah
you'd be like oh I'm 380 no I'm like
dude 8 yep yep that's a good point
or will it be will it act as an ornament
see that'd be nice yeah but then you can
have that basically open up ornaments
for every single piece of legendary
point that's a good point it's gonna be
an interesting handle to see how they
implement it because in the past it's
always been you'd have to take off
strong gear and then put on this mask
that would drop you down to next to
nothing cuz a light level and these
things would be non-existent no John
have one it might be a consumable thing
the last for like 24 hours or a week or
something like that it could be one of
those if you actually just put it on
over cuz I saw the one that was like
feel like a picture somewhere words like
you have the traveler head I feel like
some of those before were it was if you
had the in gram head but some of those
were true masks though I'm trying to
remember but my other question is as the
haunted forest is for everyone what
level do you think that's gonna be mmm I
don't know that's a hard one
um I mean it's again a scale is it going
to it well we know the activity gets
harder the deeper you go
anybody arm and the vibe I'm getting
from them is that they're trying to make
it very inclusive at first because
that's when we don't get into that now
yeah but um hmm I don't think it'll be
that hard though I would say you know
there has to be a point if you run in so
low that it's actually a challenge
otherwise everybody can do it if for 500
or above because if somebody's on d2
vanilla
only and they're capped it I don't even
remember the cap 300 mm-hmm I don't
remember good you know I was just like
if that's as high as they go but they
can step into the same activity either
it's just gonna scale to what you are or
I don't know I'm going you're cheb more
500 like asking your chair because the
point of entry has to be low so that
anybody can jump in but then as you
progress obviously gonna be rewards and
brownies and things tied to certain
things I think that's probably how they
handle it cuz I if I remember past
festive laws I never thought about them
is like super difficult activities I
remember as you went along certain quest
towards the end of it the things they
asked you to do may have increased
difficulty so I'm gonna I'm gonna
actually say it's gonna have a low low
barrier for entry is gonna probably like
500 just to start whatever you need to
start but progressively you know go up
in difficulty yeah be kind of cool if
you gets a little checkpoint so you open
one of those little doors and it's like
level 550 level you keep pushing through
a little bit so I don't know we'll see
but yeah I was like just kind of got
some questions they answer it's like
they still haven't done transmog
everybody's dying for that at some point
which is hopefully something maybe I'll
do in d2 or d3 but who knows but yeah
I'm kind of wondering how the masks work
because if you do truly drop like your
five pieces of gear if you go if your
600 and you put one on you drop to 480
that's a thing like you're gonna go get
your butt whooped in the Dreaming City
oh you just have to see I don't know cuz
the kid point that's the white I mean
cuz if that was the whole thing before
about the mask was acquiring them so you
take it on put it off take it out and
put it off it was just a consumable then
like okay some of those activities
wanted you to do whatever wearing a
specific mask and right if they want you
to go do at nightfall warns of all those
masks
I'm gonna get killed during the reenact
yeah interesting it's very very I mean
you think maybe they handle it kind of
like um what's this last one no solstice
yeah remember they had these out of
armor or something like that with
ornaments yeah maybe something I don't
know I don't know it's very very
interesting because when I mean not in
the sense that has a sense of armor but
maybe from this sense of you know you
started off really low mm-hmm no I don't
know this is a very interesting thing
that they're talking about this they're
talking about solo bands making they're
definitely making it an event this is
not something that's just gonna be just
put on a mask and run around an asset so
you know very clear to see how this is
handled yeah so crossing fingers they
also we get them will they be possible
from a collection cute latin so maybe I
don't know I'm hoping we get something
that surprises us nice little step in
the direction for the game have to see
question question yes if we actually get
the right answer for bungie right I
don't know if Steve and Scott are still
at the helm of this or even at least
making sure it's pushed in the right
direction
aye aye so far mostly have faith
absolutely absolutely
this is the forsaken has been a home run
throwing throw definitely yep so second
wave so this is one a lot of us talked
about wondered what was going on why now
there's two different schools of thought
on this one I have a feeling so when
they launched forsaken to play forsaken
you had to own all of destiny to year
one including the two expansions that's
about to change
yes effective October 16 a purchase of
Destiny to forsaken will include with
the two expansions included in the
destiny two expansion pass every player
of Destiny to who is yet to touch down
on the tangled Shore will only need the
Forsaken upgrade
our hope is that this will eliminate
some of the questions that confront a
player as they try to join the party
you think I want to know your straight
up opinion um I think it's good I think
it's got me it's something that probably
this is them breaking this out look it I
think this is them breaking protocol
they've always been bungees history or
Activision's history has always been
when the major content dropped like a
taking King comes out that major style
expansion comes out that you know
they're like hey you can't play it you
know unless you've had you know the
previous DLC before and the new one
that's that they've kind of been hard
and fast and they've been getting away
with it and we went buying it but you
know it does enforce Akins case I did
empathize with the guy who had d2 got
you know disenchanted with it or
whatever you know it just said I'm done
didn't pick up curse after bad reviews
and rightfully so could we get mad at
that guy who did a bigger business Cyrus
you know war mine comes out got you know
average do you know mid to average
reviews I can't get mad if a person says
hey you know I'm still not ready to come
back to destiny then the for Satan comes
out it gets rave reviews he's like you
know what I'm ready to come back to
destiny and now you go boom you've got
to have chorus of Osiris from war mine
to even play forsaken see I know that's
like that's one of those decisions that
I feel like was not entirely theirs yes
Activision this is this is an Activision
there's no doubt in my mind you know and
again please if you ever watched um I've
pressed uh Lord Rick hold from a hole or
he said he said he's a gaming lawyer he
does a lot of these corporation we
talked about destiny clues I have to ask
them a lot of Destiny questions so you
know these are the kind of things that
you know get worked out behind the
scenes and um you know as far as this
price structure and things of that
nature and I think this is also finally
some goodwill on their end because let's
be honest D two's launch as well as they
did financially as hard as it tapered
off sales wise you know there was a
humbling thing for them that if you
probably if they if they had their stat
guys in the book you know on deck and
they're and they're doing their forecast
how do you think destiny to as a French
I was gonna do right when it dropped out
the gate we were all in our honeymoon
phase that was what they expected to
continue throughout the expansion you
know from there from D to all the way
the war mine it dropped off some
dramatically the game was a joke
everyone you know ran for the hills
Destiny's dead that's these dead people
screaming from the hills so now that you
finally getting some goodwill back
forsaken it's this amazing content you
know why not you know why not do some
goodwill and keep because one thing we
do know is my last point one thing we do
know when you do things like that where
you you're forcing people to buy all
this additional content you know now
you're separating the base right it's
like the equivalent of a Call of Duty
with map packs oh you can't play the new
one until you have all these you gotta
mean experience no you segmenting it
you've lost your base let's get them
back I know people in this exact
situation he shots my bloody knuckles he
is destiny hard core right felt betrayed
by destiny to write each subsequent
thing I said nope is he come to me like
I need oh I know you're gonna give me a
real talk I know you and flashpoint
delivery buds if you guys talk destiny
like is this safe I couldn't tell him it
was safe with Osiris to come back I
couldn't tell him it was safe a woman
I'll be honest what I'm saying look they
did some hard things for the hardcore
war mine I don't know if everything is
all the way you want it then one for
Satan came out I'm like dude it's ready
to go
this is its back you know I'm saying all
the way weapon rolls good story good
lord great raid you know I'm saying just
boom and he's like alright and then they
look and say wait I got a by Osiris and
what just to do it
kudos to them on this one you know that
that's what I felt no Rama but this is
what they give some different aspects
what do you feel like what do you feel
were you shocked by this will you when
you read this this whole forsaken
includes Osiris and wore mine for free
so part of this is one of those where
they may have been allowed to finally be
like hey we got to open the gates we
want to get more people let us have some
freedom here but on the other side it's
like
they got their initial push mm-hmm they
got the Forsaken they got the people who
bought the bundles who bought the
collections so I mean this basically
shoots the collection or basically drops
the price on it because I saw the price
dropped on the clapping actually makes
more sense thing come through in the
collection drop down to 40 bucks mm-hmm
because that basically is the price of
for a second so yeah basically drops the
price on everything which is probably
not a bad thing some people who may feel
like they got shafted because they feel
like be like I had to buy this whole
thing just to get forsaken which really
was just like 20 bucks on top of
forsaken so right depending on what you
had paid for or not it was probably the
value of one of those expansions anyway
so I mean it wasn't the end of the world
but people who were like oh if I just
would have waited if you just would have
waited you would have missed out on all
this already and there's always a price
for being an early adopter no matter
what you're doing so the nice thing
about this is they didn't forget the
early adopters mm-hmm and this is the
piece that I want shout out so you could
see both sides of the coin you could be
like oh now they're gonna let you and
after they got all their initial push in
the money but on the other side they
could have just been like well okay
finally we're gonna lower the curtain
let more people in and that's it I
coulda just said hey force Aikens all
you need now and not had any more on
this paragraph they could have stopped
right here on this line yeah no more but
they typed some more mm-hmm what about
us is what everyone who already
purchased more say can is acting your
vanguard we appreciate you if you're
beginning a hunt on day one you were
there when the first raid first raid
finished changed the drinking city even
part of the conversation that is breathe
enthusiasm back in the tower for you and
only the players like you we have a
collection of veterans rewards as an
expression of our appreciation for being
on the front lines every guardian who
played forsaken prior to October 16th
will receive the following bundle a
unique emblem which by the way is pretty
cool
yes let's go ahead and zoom this guy in
here oh yeah you can get it so you got
like a tiger stripe emblem with what
looks to be kind of a badass like a
little black tiger you've got a shader a
jewel and they have if you got this you
got to exotic emotes now what exotic
emotes cost sometimes we know the iron
banner
here's the cost like 10 bucks right now
alone might even cover your difference
depending but you got a coin flip emote
knife trick emote and you've got a
consumable bundle now it's just like one
of each of these somebody forget who did
it I think it was tasks it was like I'm
gonna need about 300 of those finest
matter waves to make my early adoption
workers like you know it's something
going crazy they'd be the best at work
cool bundle that uh yeah give me just
pastor workhorse just yeah by the way
here's fifty master of course for being
part of it so but they did not have to
do this scientist me and most you guys
may be like hey it's cosmetics it's
boons it's not that great it is
something don't guess so not to be a
Bungie chaleur apologist or whatever you
want to call I can completely understand
because there's some people in one of my
friends was the one who did not get warm
line he ended up buying them because
they were on sale they were down to like
ten bucks they were pretty cheap so if
you wanted to jump in then you got the
opportunity to but if you were just like
hey I want to wait and now you want to
do it you're good yeah so I don't think
this is a bad thing just because it
brings more people back into the game
which is pretty much all we're asking
for the more players the better the more
newbies that can run around and crucible
that I can shoot and have a chance to
kill they're better let's let's don't
let don't misunderstand me saying I
think this is a good thing I mean not
understanding that some people may truly
feel shafted because they're like if I
would have just waited a little bit what
what's the deal so completely you
understand that you know I will say that
again let me put cuz you don't say we're
chilling for bungie but at the end of
the day it's like the option is do
nothing right which is you just drop the
price you don't do anything for that
community who actually was there day one
and you pissed people off so at least I
don't feel they're tone-deaf anymore
ways like before they would just do
something like that and you know it's
like wow what about the guys that were
there day one you know that kind of I've
seen companies other companies do stuff
like that so I like that I like and
actually this set if I recall
they've actually used this tiger-stripe
thing before in a similar fashion I
believe during the taken king air
because I remember seeing a sparrow
this kind of this design it's veteran
kind of design that you've been here
before kind of deal so this is something
that they have done in the past before
I'll just I can't get my timeline
correct if it was taken king or if it
was right before easy triumph there was
some cool thing like this they did for
the vets and listen I like it you know
hey we could always ask for more you
know of course you know my Sega I'm
completely satisfied with this yeah of
course I've been greedy not someone but
it's just some type of acknowledgment to
that you know to that base oh I'm good
with it man ultimately the gamers went
out gamers went out for people who are
have been on the fence at least they can
jump in you know I mean you want more
community you want more people playing
destiny that's ultimately what this as
well yeah so I mean it could be more it
could be less
somebody in chat saying hey it could be
ship or a spare or something like that
which would be cool to again still just
a cosmetic piece he's like I'm not
greedy he's like I want all the things
can I have a full armor set too but
overall it's one of those pieces where
they are trying to acknowledge the base
they are trying to get more people in
they got the approval to basically open
the gates a little more and they're just
doing what they can for those who they
know feel like they may be like hey and
they're like here's here's a token of
our appreciation
thank you for boosting this game to what
it has been absolutely all they can do
so the tiger tiger stripe black shader
and veterans name plate emblems arts are
exclusive to players who earn this
bundle by playing forsaken prior to
October 16th you have till Monday
you've been more exotic emotes will be
available on ever verse sometime in the
future all names are subject to change
so yep
and they're just gonna be I think in
ever verse as either just something to
come through for bright dust or maybe
just a in gram or anything like that I
don't know if you're gonna pop in you're
in gram or what how that's gonna go
I think other people may be able to get
them to it looks like mmm but I think
we're just gonna get them straight up
straight up so at least my understanding
so pretty cool stuff and again it's just
the tip of the hat to those who started
it out and they're just saying thanks
nothing wrong with that nothing wrong
right there thank you for playing and
thank you for being the first to accept
it's what we've created exactly what
they're doing exactly and and thank you
for not leaving people who are on the
fence about destiny for sake because
this is great content we want people to
play it we want you know you want the
online population to be to be grown so
this this kind of thing to be honest Yui
I hope I'm curious to see moving forward
if they will adopt this from now on you
know maybe when it releases you know the
first early adopters going we get that
Forsaken you know we had most of us
already had that content previous
expansion content anyway so it really
didn't affect the hardcore right so
maybe this is a new thing now and with
the especially let's be honest
especially in this rise of my push back
towards micro transactions you know EA
has been getting hit um take twos been
getting hit with 2k you know that's the
people legislation is coming I mean
whether we agree or disagree that's
another entirely pocket for that but the
point of the matter is that a lot of
these big-name publishers are going to
have to adopt different strategies now
and the only thing that I can say which
was negative in the best in community as
far as the you know we will both agree
vesting doesn't my nickel endow me with
Michael transactions I never felt that
way I never felt you know Cosmetics and
all that give you something
exactly he's never been that game but
the only thing you could accuse destiny
it was all well they always nickel and
diming with the expansions and they
making you get this and that and if they
do this where's like early adopters boom
first month okay cool
and then you wait what is it now we're
uh about a full word about like a full
month now from four seconds launch right
yeah about six weeks yeah Oh exactly so
now you go okay six weeks boom you know
what for those guys on the fence now
palmistry I wouldn't mind if they adopt
is you know I wouldn't i I think it's a
nice gesture honestly yeah so I mean
that's kind of thing you think it's like
something that overwatch there is no
characters there's no progression
there's no weapons like that is the only
thing but that stuff is still cosmetic
too right some of those roles are
absolutely trashed which will take a
little bit
I mean I played that a little bit I was
like every time all I would get is like
a little bit of gold which takes a
thousand to do anything or a duplicate
of something and yeah I just never got
so on it but catch on here yeah it's
just the tip of that hat and a thank you
and generally just positive stuff
personally as a big fan of this it's
like me I've been playing I don't know
how many hours have already got out of
this game anyway
so I got plenty of time out of it and if
it just opens up the universe for more
gives people an option and I mean
they're about to go up against Call of
Duty like today which is available shout
out to blackout it'll be interesting
you've got coming in like two weeks and
a lot of stuff coming so for them to try
and keep people around or say hey do you
want to check this out as well or a
Christmas gift or something they're
opening that you know door that was
blocking to be like hey you had to buy
it all before nope not anymore so
overall I'm alright with it
yep what else we got sorry guys taking
care my nose okay to know out of the
iron and into the fire this is why I
said there's too much crap to do iron
banners next week as well enough time
yes overload iron banner comes back
along with festival lost along with by
the way heads up week three in the
Dreaming city so yeah yeah you don't
have your third subclass and you missed
that you got to jump in for that if you
didn't make it through the shedder throw
an organ or wish under you've got to
grind that one out this is why I'm glad
Festival loss of three weeks I don't
know what to do first
but banners changing with 2.0 point for
the bounties have been altered so
they're not quite as lengthy and
everything drops powerful gear remember
that every single bounty now offers
powerful gear as a reward so even if you
do some of the quicker ones you'll get
some powerful gear if you make the
longer longer grinds you've got what six
options I mean since the powerful gear
is no joke now they may not be the big
boost if you're at five eighty but six
pieces altogether that's solid my advice
on these is you're going through like if
you're leveling up throughout the week
if you knock one out early maybe don't
like pop that one until you're like hey
I've got a couple things that are lower
a couple things that are hired get
ranked at those points where it's gonna
start really balancing you out use those
as those little fillers cuz I don't
imagine these are gonna be Queens Queens
bounties type like dreaming city level
light bumps like the other stuff we'll
be right but every bounty has been
reduced in time to grind so light bear
super kills down five from twenty five
to twenty match completions this is
probably the bigger 30 matches is a lot
yeah yeah I mean if you live in crucible
and you park your little tint in the
corner next to shacks and alright
Cumaean selects coach I'm good
like you'll probably have thirty on your
first day most of us want to do some
other stuff but crucible man over here
kognito is like I need three hundred
what do you listen I agree with you I
played when I completed all those
bounties and I'm like man that took a
while it really was a time investment I
love I love crucible but if I put myself
in everyone else's shoes like you know
an average - you know mid-level average
interest in crucible you know that's the
slog that's a slog I have to give it cut
for me even miles like man I still got
all these type of kills and get I gotta
get these I gotta get super kill or
whatever and you know heavy kills it's a
lot man so listen this these are cool
adjustments and in note the main thing
is that every single one now offers
powerful gear you know and you know you
shout them killing the chat yeah i man's
gonna be a good source now I am Ben is
gonna be good source or powerful gear
and I like that and the thing I like
most about it it reminds me of d1
because for guys like me who like to
play a lot more crucible than the
average PvE guy like that means I can
live in the crucible and still benefit I
can still benefit while you guys are out
doing you know the haunted forest
because if I just wanted to play
crucible day I can still stay on the
track and I think that's what d1 always
did better than d2 which was depending
on the style of player you was if you
just want to play crucible you had that
you
compared I mean which go and you had on
yet the true meaning of war bounty and
you had trials of Osiris you could
literally MaxLite by doing just those
activities yeah
so this balance that out a little more I
mean even listen to death dado at one
point it was just like guys it's the
first iron banner you know it's gonna
change they're just not trying to throw
it all to you at once what do you know
like two and a half three weeks later
BAM here we are
so yeah powerful gear coming from those
shout out to I don't know how to say
your name man type it in chat but it's
you lad 86 I'm like obviously that but I
don't know he was just saying also is
like there's too many powerful engrams
in the game in his opinion I'm casual in
months ago and now I'm 581 so yeah by
like you'd Latin he's also asking about
the prime buff he's like it might be
broken he got three prime engrams
it kinda depends on how frequently and
how often you've been playing I was
literally going through my Tuesday grind
with both my characters I got one
between both so maybe it's like one a
day maybe it's supposed to be like how
much you played cute lat ok cool I said
alright well I know we talked about it
before yeah basically I was just saying
it's like there are a lot of ways to get
to max level and now there's even more
raw that the casual picking up the game
can get up to that max level I still
wish there was some type of either
caveat or asterisks or 610 from doing
the raid something but we've covered
that before but yeah just throw now that
they're cute it's like I I feel yeah
believe because you can do you can do a
lot of things in this game not touch in
game and still be max level which for me
is still a little bit of an issue for
those who want to actually get that
final accomplishment no no no I mean you
know I don't you know I always feel like
you know the hardest activity should
give you know get you to the max light
and stuff like that and I always
encourage that kind of play because
ultimately you want people to play this
great content this is great content so
why avoid it all the time I'm not you
know engaging in its own you know I'm
with it as far as thought you guys
point in reference to to all-powerful
yeah I kind of like the way it is now
because it incentivizes me everyday to
log in every day because you see like a
daily powerful get man I can let me do
this I have to set plans and I'm okay
what's the most efficient thing I can do
today if I have limited time I can do
okay
three-game it matches get this I can
live in strikes for a minute or you know
I'm saying I can do crucible form you
know two to five matches stuff like that
and then when you do the weeklies out
the way each day something new will pop
on come reset so for me it just makes
the world a little bit more living I
don't know if that if you understand
where I'm coming from me yeah like I I
just like that every day I can do
something is something new to do that's
gonna grant me that source you know if
you you and let's be honest to the other
thing is even though you get a powerful
grid it doesn't guarantee you the boost
like let's be right cuz they've been
many times I've gotten kinetic weapons
in the same slot that don't give me or
you get a piece of you know you don't
get that piece of armor or piece of
weapon slot that actually will affect
your light going up cuz still orange II
with that as well so I'm cool with it
man I actually like how it is I mean
can't get off destiny so that does so
for me way too much way too much mmm yep
so yeah that's just kind of one of those
things that's it's hard to balance and
they're trying to go between not going
too casual which is where we got to or
we were in the world of destiny to year
one they threw everything at you
everything was too easy and then they
kind of flipped it all the way to the
other side on for sake and they're kind
of letting some people ease in that
first month grind has been one hell of a
grind it's been legit so I mean opening
opening the doors more I mean I will say
some of these are like I mean match
completions 15 match completions if you
spend 15 crucible matches in there you
do you can do one and get your daily
done sometimes
so I mean spending 15 an iron banner
there's still some time in these you
can't just like fall you can't just like
trip over powerful engrams so shout out
to the art design as well because once
again somehow making your own banner
you're look different weapons are by the
way pretty good ones from what I hear so
it's yeah yep
so it's the Fox and let me zoom in on
this one here we go so we got what is it
the I don't even have both of these I
think I got one yeah I'm trying to
remember what the hell they're called
cuz they say the Wolves in the Fox oh
it's a sniper and the pulse which are
both good I think yeah
pulse the pulse is really good closet
assignment thing yeah claws of the wolf
is that clausal yes something like that
yeah you know I want to know is solid
from what I hear that one's good one's
really good and then I think the sniper
rifle I've seen people use it I don't
think I've got it but it always like
just it has it so look it's cool yeah I
need a rocket man I was hoping for a
rocket rocket look just so bad that bad
omens tracking Oh
cluster bombs like that's the only
rocket launcher that anyone wants cuz
every other one does not see that's kind
of an annoying thing to me I mean I
guess there's a point of some Rockets
having some perks and not but like I
mean if it's a rocket launcher like
sleeveless I'm pretty sure that one
cannot have tracking in it kind of
cluster cuz I've got one with it but it
doesn't seem to want to roll with
tracking and I don't know if it can kind
of annoying but the other rocket
launcher can't do it Oh from gambit
which is even more annoying because
that's harder to get packages from him
so yep
it's a breach now so but some cool gear
so yeah foxes and wolves we will be out
in battle and remember every time you do
one of those bounties you're gonna get
powerful gear anyway from doing the
bounty and then with your tokens you're
gonna be able to unlock a piece of armor
or two of these weapons from them so
plenty to do yes you also can't scroll
past this double Valor and traversal the
lovers out there double Valor may not
incentivize you maybe do your you know
you're dreaming city maybe do your
haunted forest jump into the shattered
throne but over the weekend if you want
some Valor from Monday through reset
earth what would that be Friday through
I said basically
in town it's going to be triple valor
over the weekend so jump in the crucible
jump in the iron banner that's your time
to grind out so maybe you split your
week maybe you thought it Forrest maybe
you do a shout of throne and then come
Friday then you jump back on your
crucible wagon and you're good to go you
got options man you got eyes for
crucible this is crucible dream I'm on
my reg ex guy Oh beautiful beautiful
perfect this weekend so see if I guess
not well it's next weekend which is good
because that family intend this weekend
not gonna give as much time to play this
weekend I know just got up to 583 and
I'm like I got a I got a I kind of got
to get me some of that but yeah so
definitely spend some time we got the
Valor coming up apparently if you're
reading these words in English they're
going to work on other localized
versions of the blog which is impressive
so I guess they're gonna work on some
translations that's one thing to
remember guys if they put anything in
the game they have like 12 languages to
cover nothing is gonna be fast when you
do that mmm because if you've ever seen
something of a localization that goes
poorly not a good thing get that stuff
right yes and in case you really wanted
some you can make your paper masks the
Mac this is you saw on Twitter Cosmo was
wearing this mask sitting in front of
his computer and working on the table
this thing is apparently bigger than I
thought it was clearly it's not not
small and yeah if it fits Kosmos head it
was good to go so got a couple options
you can get the free paper craft chicken
template courtesy bungee soar you've
also got scorn shacks and aldrin Psalm
so you got your masks to put on these
are just like they take time to build
like paper crafts so you can literally
print them out yeah if you guys don't
see that go look up cosmos Twitter he's
got a fun little arias and if you get
any of these things that you want mask
wise you can actually get this emblem so
I know they're gonna get some quick
stuff that way which is always nice see
these are ones that like hey if somebody
spends like a dollar on a mask
gets an emblem cool half of the bungee I
don't know how much of bungee stores
like proceeds go to st. jude's anyway if
not most all of them so I mean it's
always to a good cause so it's like hey
if I'm like is there a t-shirt I want
they're always a good fabric there's
finally got myself this of Heroes shirt
that took a while
I ordered it like before I think before
the event ended but it took way too long
but I did find finally get it excuse me
yes I'm like all over the place with my
voice this morning oh okay but for the
schedule so two point 0.4 we got a patch
coming up that's just gonna be normal
downtime just gonna go down earlier on
Tuesday morning doesn't matter because
I'm never at my house but it looks like
it should be back up normal time so
going down earlier than usual for like a
reset or just a tick over so we'll be
down for about three hours nothing major
major nothing crazy look at the patch up
and then festival loss will be launching
you just make sure you have to actually
have the patch for a festival a lost if
you don't reboot reload redownload
whatever you got to do you jump back in
there there are a couple known issues if
you guys know about them look at them
there's an ascendant challenge emblem
that's out there that's not updating
correctly PC still having some FPS
issues occasionally that's an issue
there is also an issue with Petra's run
yes so there's an issue with people gave
me kick back to orbit or being
disconnected like killing a run
I like Petra's run so if you're gonna go
on Petros run you're gonna try and
flawless the raid
you better have a rock-solid connection
go call your cable coming to be like hey
you drop my connection now I'm going to
literally walk over there and rip your
service out so but yeah overall just you
know by the way I want to shut that out
can you believe that's actually a thing
yeah ribbons bein title that's what I'm
saying
that's that's not gonna happen for me
it's gonna happen I was like one of my
friends was working on the Riven fight
long enough with some people they kinda
had the damaged pipe fire damage phase
it was just like so like you've seen the
raid enough now you've seen what's in
there with the symbol
and everything do you think it's like is
it really necessary for them to make for
fish for birds for dragons if you okay
so if you're not gonna do things like
one like Roman numerals be like 1 2 3 4
if it's not gonna be that can at least
be separate animals maybe a bird like
like a dragon holding stick on this side
a dragon holding an upside down like and
that's why people made those things
where you can say like you know eight
snake like infinity things like that
stuff I mean you can say I'm quick but
it's like what if it was just snake up
in enough distinction in there why you
have to make four of the seems like
those are some of the things where a
buddy of mine was saying it's like I
know the reigns difficult but I mean
just the call-outs it's like it's almost
overly so and I know people do it it's
like it's it's been done obviously but
one of his friends did the patron five
times already and kept getting oh my god
they did the patron five times and got
guitar arrows I would probably give up
or like petition bunch and be like dude
go look at my game play it's in there
I'm not doing this again my hair is gone
all of my hair is gone so it's just a
like I understand they made it hard now
this is one of the things I was talking
about him if they ever wanted to use
guided games in a great way what if they
literally like halved the mechanics in
the raid and made that the guided games
raid I mean seriously like take Kali for
example right say if you say there's
only one symbol on each there's no say
two people hold down a platform instead
of having two so a little platform you
literally could have three people Sherpa
three people mm-hmm I mean that's that
fight that I thought of but you could do
that for a guided Games raid and
actually have that thing be viable
that's what they need to do we've got
like that type of they need to make
since they made the raid basically they
made it hard mode that's just the only
option right they need like a guided
game's easy version so people can
experience like the damn best
on ten in the game yeah all right listen
I'm with that I want the mode to be
utilized I mean it's the future that
they touted at the launch of their see
to it it still hasn't really been
expounded upon and still not in a good
smart so instead of like that's a great
idea instead of using these grandiose or
let's do the whole raid maybe they have
these mini versions you know meaning
where you take the kylie encounter you
take the sure old qi encounter and it's
just the encounter
you said I'm saying because let's be
honest finding six people to do
something and then also finding people
that got that length of a time
commitment to complete all of that you
know that's challenging so I think that
is a good idea kind of break it up by
section yeah so I mean for the sure OT
fight when you get to the puzzles just
have one maybe there's maybe they take
the crystals out maybe you just have to
kill all the adds and then you can
damage her trying to think of more guess
maybe there's I mean just like literally
half of half the encounter something
used to left out three people who know
what they're doing but you have three
Sherpa three people looking for newbies
I mean make voice chatter requirement
there's no way you can do it without
voice chat but I will say this if
they're gonna do stuff like that to sure
I kind of will feel away if they're
getting similar style rewards for that
kind of raid run if you know what I mean
you get me because they if they're doing
you know puzzles with you know doctor
full difficulty of the giant because
they're new I don't want them coming out
there with you know curated God rolls
like we've got to be careful with the
rewards on the Sherpa
if they be interpreting this type of
where if you did the Sherpa trade that'd
be a point where my whole idea of the
in-game content being how you get to 600
maybe the shipper rate stops giving you
a boost at like five eighty five ninety
and maybe the curator URLs are not an
option it's only random great thousand
voices straight up doesn't come from
there that's what I'm saying like they
can't have a full loop pool and full pot
you know because that will be exploited
that will be absolutely would but
I think that'd be a way I mean they want
more people to do their best stuff right
like no grass not his name actually but
that's a sorter handle but those guys
who do the raid they're like they do
content they're like me I'm 20% of
people get to see this stuff maybe 30
like depending on how many people jump
in find that way make that stuff easier
for a guided version so explaining like
hey here's these 16 symbols mm-hmm like
the way definitely you I definitely yeah
that would be but yeah I mean shout out
some people do in Petra's around that is
insane but just that made me think of
like other stuff about the raid that
yeah I mean when you get into it it's
like yeah you got to figure out you got
to know what to call and that's just
part of like learning a difficult rate
it's not meant to be easy but some of
that stuff was to a point of almost
excessive like I mean the sixteen
symbols could be 16 different symbols if
they're not gonna be like you know
number one two three not have numbers be
like okay Tiger whale fish like make
them fairly obviously distinct so you
still have a lot of things to know but
they're not like yeah
Tiger left tiger right like come on
really get their left and right crossed
on their head for a second you wipe an
entire raid run like little stuff like
that is the kind of the annoyances
sometimes so yeah but guys they got the
a couple music videos actually so they
got a Destiny parody for no scrubs and
then a smells like raid spirit so both
of those oh yeah they were pretty good
so we got the ones on here we got Milan
games coming up on PC for Bungie
bounties these I'm sorry if I don't know
you guys as streamers not calling you
out these are the just the ones I know
yeah that's probably most of them I've
heard I know looking about wipe they've
been streamers and stuff I don't know as
many of the other ones but shout outs
all of these guys like go jump in see if
you if these are times when you play
destiny see if you pair up against him
if you're on the platform if you're on
PlayStation if you're on PC not a lot of
Xbox level in this chart sorry about
that yeah I noticed woe is us is the ex
boxers just join the PC
it's time sir X with X you ain't got a
ch2 I like how I got HD up the levels I
got it it's very expensive for you guys
to do it that's another discussion well
that's a different thing yeah yeah well
HDR is a little different when it's like
144 Hertz it's gonna look real fancy
when we do get there but yeah it takes a
little while for that to go from oh
here's your general TV stuff at like 30
frames per second 60 or 120 frames per
second at the fidelity and 4k and all
the cousins but when it gets there it's
beautiful that is most of all we got you
got anything else for the week went
quicker than I thought it would actually
be born with a long point um I mean I am
definitely definitely excited for next
week um obviously we got the patches
coming
right we got um to which that we have
one launching in conjunction with this
one correct yeah the point 0.4 is to dip
and blend the two weeks from now will be
the kind of I don't wanna say bigger
patch but it's definitely patched - let
me see let me find it real quick correct
course I have another monitor bonus I
think it was last week they talked about
it yeah
that's done yeah that's malfeasant yeah
so 2 point 0.5 rebalancing the some
perks you've got sword damage in PvE
fusion rifle and PvE the malfeasant
quest stuff yeah 2.0 for that one dhadak
duplicates the nightfall exclusive drops
master records that stuff's all coming
so that's actually probably gonna be the
bigger one on the 30th yet known if it's
but still for me I just wanna know what
to go over with the one that's coming on
Tuesday 16 you know obviously we're
gonna get more things than edge you know
edge transient legendary heavy slack
power slam that's one but remember guys
dust off those Scout rifles
yeah scout rifles the damage is gonna be
buffed
so that nerf that
they you know that stealth nerf that was
on Scouts since cuz I don't know if you
guys know Scouts feel terrible in PvE
oh they suck they suck they're not good
especially in gambit because I'm like 10
that's what I really think would be
effective and I want to use them and I
can't so thus those off that should be
good looking forward to that and the
rest is like more little quality of life
stuff in that but don't sleep on that
little update is what I'm saying so I'm
I am personally looking forward to that
dr. Ward Enchantix less edge trends it's
broken game oh yeah you know fired
fluids and WD crooked Fang all that
stuff's gonna be in there which is
always a good thing
scouts getting a boost that they
desperately need like even just oh and
I'm sitting there thinking I'm like I
don't I get a scout rifle it just goes
straight to my vault it's like I want to
setup them to literally scout rifle
vault it like doesn't even matter
transmat effects into the collections
will be a nice little thing just to
clean some stuff up which isn't really
an issue the name over the lost sectors
kind of takes away the need for me to
make some videos but that's probably
okay there yeah one on the thirtieth
sword damage in PvE PvE viability of
malfeasance in PvE and gambit activities
so like those for your big already Titan
shield the exotic duplicate drops things
like that but the higher chance for
Forsaken drops it fall rewards are gonna
have that continued addition of
basically higher and higher chance at
that exclusive drop if you don't get it
keep running it and that chance will go
up master records are rewards for wanted
spider bounties and scrapper bounties
I'm kind of curious the number so if
they just make it one I'm still gonna be
like but I mean that's an insane that's
a way to go grind like you know we'll
see you like fifteen of them or
something yes reducing the time for
single shader deletion and then a fix
for ascendant primeval servitor for the
wrong team like just yeah yeah thing
they've done they had a patches for
pretty much all of 2018 January February
March April May like they have patches
we got warm lined out we had more stuff
coming we got forsaken we got two
patches in October
November is probably gonna be it sounds
low-key but maybe like a quality-of-life
before the black armory drops yeah
and then black armory have you heard
that there's like a black weapon type
yes and there's a lot of truth to these
rumors ready to been popping there's a
lot of truth to it ain't on whoever
whoever leaked basically most things
with forsaken has been doing it again so
I don't know if it's bungee being like
here go leak this stuff like you kind of
know what you're talking about because I
feel like some of it unless somebody
just like put a little black bug on one
of their servers and be like I've got
all the information and hack in or
somebody's doing it intentionally cuz
man that stuff is way too accurate I
don't know where they could get it from
if they don't have an inside source
because it's super accurate and and now
I know it's got its some truth to it is
because of the fact that um remember
during the Forsaken um Game Informer
remember they were leaking like crazy
we're giving us all its forsaken blow
out coverage like literally two months
before four so you can drop number this
and during that time it they talked
about it they said they did mention you
know they thought about a black bear
entire or something like that for the
future but you know that well none of
that stuff will be in forsaken but they
mention a black weapon type specific
that's gonna be you know something with
more of or hierarchy or rarity than
exotics themselves so you don't even
know how that's gonna work no exotic and
a black weapon equipped I know like like
I mean when the dude looks like he's
holding something that looks like it
fell off of a ship like cannon it's a
huge looking railgun I don't know what
it looks like it looks like the size of
my body turned sideways so he just says
something absolutely I brocco repeat it
but it's absolutely like we're talking
we're joking about sparrows that we want
nor just like 170 sparrow speed actually
the edge shell I want that on an edge
transit or shell that's a must shout dog
shadow wolf or might a said have you
seen because of it yeah I cannot those
in PvP where my god I don't care whose
Rockets what I mean swords
what else was in there Rockets swords
heavies you don't need one yeah man I
would get like four or five bills Hill's
heavy machine
well I wouldn't I would get that heavy
weapon my goal was to get that machine
Lord Meadows yes every time so all of
that those things so I'm curious how
much ammo is gonna come back for those
that'll be kind of a key mm-hmm because
I mean you had to have a decent clip you
had to have like I mean it's like
usually three or four they're pretty
quick and powerful shots they die fast
but I mean you got to have like 2025
shot I mean you gotta have a decent
amount of ammo in that heavy weapon or
heavy to be able to do anything to
compare with grenade launchers now you
have to have a decent sized clip so yeah
absolutely
I'm still really curious about the black
armory and the heavy machine guns and
the new raid lair what oh yo we got a
salute them real quick - we're not going
back to the Jiva city to do the raid
later no no that is progress that is
what we could not understand what I
gotta call my man gaming addict Oh
shadow daddy people like yeah we need to
bring him off but no seriously but um he
when I I don't think he knows so I'm
gonna break the news tool which is yo
his biggest complaint against d2 raids
Rae layers well the fact that everything
always went back to the Leviathan that
the story was not can you know connected
you know I'm Santa matically to the raid
layer and black armory looks like it's
doing that we got that gaunt character
you know who's apparently had law from
d1 on some fusion rifle I don't even
remember but that's necessary and then
on yeah apparently like I said it's
gonna be for the rumors either the e DZ
right or is it the EDC or is it Titan
where the you know idiocy and somehow
maybe infects to yes that's what I heard
too so that's pretty exciting I'm
and even though that works because of X
is not on X has not been on earth mm-hmm
I'm very curious about it
this is cool curious to see what is the
whole mystery of this gaunt character
and to see what we're gonna go up
against it well I mean it's like they
call it up but one last thing they're
calling in a bubble location so some
type of expansion oh yeah like an EDD so
it's the vibe I'm getting like lambs or
I don't know if I I mean like a like Abe
sew it on to the area or is it on its
own the vibe I'm like almost like an
extension of so I don't know it's good
it's gonna be interesting I I just like
how all this is sounding and again
keeping the narrative of the story
campaign of a dlc into aralia i will not
complain about shortness --is of raid
layers if they do it because let's be
real right eater of worlds is a great
raid later far from mechanic standpoint
and it was decent it's a good vibe right
yeah but it's just like it just didn't
have anything really to do with anything
you know overall overarching story so to
see this kind of stuff and as long as
they do you know the narrative couple
cinematics here and there I'm not
expecting last wish I'm gonna be you
know saying I'm not laughing you can't
know about it's a way that big lair I'm
gonna be realistic actually but there or
what I'm saying is either already off on
the right foot in my opinion when I hear
things like that what do you think I
mean for me there's enough in the
Dreaming city it could be there because
it's an entire destination it's not just
been like start the raid and then go
down you know as you said apartment to
be we've said it multiple times you
don't go like down the stairs instead of
up the stairs like that's in the
Dreaming city it has enough space and
room where they could totally make like
literally a new portal to go in a place
like a new they could put something in
there but if it is its own
self-contained story that progresses it
forward I could all I'm on board either
way so so I was like if it was in the
Dreaming city it's a full destination
they got plenty of space they could do
anything with that but if it's or if
it's own thing my only issue with the
off
that talked me I mean if it's evz it
connects cuz we know mercury was a waste
um but and if it's something like plate
lanes that would be kind of cool I don't
I don't picture it being that big uni
though because that was like a rise of
iron expansion that was a noticeable
chunk for you know a full expansion as
it's just an annual past thing as it's
in your mind like a ten dollar piece of
content I don't know how it's gonna work
like if it's gonna like over take the
EDC and it completely revamps it maybe
they little bit like a maybe they give
it just a cosmetic overdo I'm trying to
there's words they're not coming to my
head right now that there are better
words for that but yeah I'm kind of
curious and then also gaunt apparently
he's also EXO yes but he doesn't have a
number yes
I'd that is interesting he's like I
don't know if because he runs the DM
armory it's like well you can't kill me
because I got the best weapons ever and
now you get a chance to see him I don't
know as far as some stuff to I heard a
lot of things with him there's some
light emission apparently the rail is
also secrets about him and maybe he
don't want us to fight is it's a lot
going on with this yeah so I mean if
this is party I mean if they could do it
right if we got a decent rate layer a
couple encounters they know we want
bosses more than one so if they can even
throw two in there with maybe a jumping
puzzle something fun something kind of
extends the story gives us more to do
and see that I would like to as you said
if it was Eid easy with a new coat of
paint and that is how you progress a
game forward and that is something that
I would really like to see yeah
absolutely
I'm excited again keeping expectations
in check we've had an amazing expansion
with forsaken you know this is not a
full-blown expansion of that level this
is a you know this is an expansion in
itself and it's gonna have content and
it's gonna have a raid layer but it's
just excited to see you know what what
is gonna be shout out the dark shadow
over my check he said um you would like
for the rail layer completions to
average like 90 minutes not too long not
too short a ward over in my chat just
broke me he's like I'd like to see us
fight taken your attic
DMV workers in
the raid lair maybe one how can it could
be you take a certain symbol then you
have to wait three hours until they call
that symbol now serving jumping fish
jumping fish yeah I just like alright
alright now now we're getting a little
off track there oh yeah so I mean just
even just a little bit's I've heard the
data mining whatever's going on for that
thing November is gonna be cool it's
gonna be a bit of a downtime because
people are gonna be buried at red dead
stuff like that give it some give it a
little breathing room and then start
typing it back up for that Annual Pass
for whatever's coming with the dart the
forge the armory and all that stuff and
honestly like if even half of this craps
true I'm gonna be happy yeah absolutely
but yeah do stuff like that to have your
have your expansions change you like
like change the game use the spaces you
want but give them a new coat of paint
so then everybody who's playing is like
oh man that's cool but you just can't
get to like you can't get to the raid
lair or you can't get to the black
armory without the expansion yes cool
I'm cool this is good stuff mega time to
Train keep rolling good times and
destiny man this is just like we we
complained about concert and now we just
care I you know what's so funny
realistically I can't even legitimately
think about black armor I can't believe
it's so close and I feel like I even
then all I need to do it for sake you
know like shattered throne next week I
gotta work on the wish in there it means
I gotta run that thing like multiple
times they're there in stride they're in
the right stride right now and I think
it's very key for them because I
remember we talked about this in old
flashpoints you know we know stuff some
stuff is looming you know we got the red
dads you got you know you got you know
ant them and all that stuff next to the
vision to you know early but next year
but to see them and this good run and
it's just good to see and it just shows
me like look man that's the ain't going
out without a fight man they gonna be
here you know yeah because they make it
very dusty right now makes it very hard
for me
to play other games when I'm in the
house it's very hard yes it's it's such
a selfish game so many good things to
know are you if you haven't read it yet
since I know you travel and use your
switch a lot do you have of course now
see that's why this is why the switch
saves me because when I'm at home
destiny xbox one' next it does just
couldn't that's too soon my life did I
am all my friends my entire clan
it's insane I'm playing that constantly
but then when I'm not home I still have
these game experiences that that's why I
get a lot of my third party stuff on the
switch so I can at least play because I
don't would play it at home so how much
have you played on that I kind of got
into a little more recently how to print
like I was going through and I was doing
like five Tiananmen or unsaid I finally
had like a I finally beat the like first
boss that came across the concierge
mm-hmm got him the first time so that
was cool so I literally just down low I
just started because what did what it
was how I played it yet only funny
standpoint because I was gonna buy and
Kaiba to Lord Kanha shot him he told me
wait because um Nintendo game sharing
started oh we did yes we do sharing and
I'm like always like let me at least
download it before you know I forget cuz
I like oh you pick that up good I don't
have to pick that up that kind of thing
so yeah that's what we do shoutout to
katsu on that one now that's a feature
by Nintendo Xbox gamer but it's about
the best time it's ever been to be a
destiny two-player so all you guys have
been in chat it's been lit this morning
cue blunt welcome you're definitely um
running things this morning over at mind
shadow wolf smell those sinister all you
guys yes a lot of new faces in the chat
- don't shout jack 400 people man good
aqwal if I'm pronouncing that correct
you have a lot of cool people to chat
thanks for engaging this man this is
final
so this was actually a pretty good one
to wrap it up on Jethro
what he's curious what is everyone's
favorite activity in forsaken favorite
activity could be strike could be gambit
map could be shattered thrown so anybody
in chat on both sides what is your
favorite activity in forsaken short
seconds are you gonna make me go first
what you gotta go by its your chat talk
too much today so that's good oh all
right so I wait chat I don't know why my
chat you so what I'll say for me
favorite activity I can't believe I love
gambit as much as I do because of the
fact um I think what it is now I've
really got good strategies and loadouts
and like I'm really shy adapter he said
love so give even with people better
because I know how to play it
um you just can't peek me you gotta hide
behind things yeah look you gotta be
safe you gotta look at your radar but um
yeah it's gambit man because it's just
that whole strategy of melting a
primeval you know and I have great I'm
coming in there with Luna factions you
know so I can melt by primeval pretty
fast I'm I don't you know it's funny I
don't invade a lot my mind I'm actually
a good solo play I don't play a lot of
my clan mates and game I use each time
I'm playing by myself and one thing that
I do is my specialty is I am going to
focus when the invader comes in and I'm
gonna kill invaders right once invaders
are killed then I'm gonna put my well
irradiance down you know and I'm gonna
support the team and we're gonna melt
this primeval so my thing and then I'm
giving out blessings and divine
protection like I'm the ultimate support
gambit player I think that's why my
team's win because there's anybody and
if I have if I'm teamed with someone
like an addict who's good at like going
and invading and killing forget it you
just healing prime me so yeah but I got
really they were made in Gary even more
is I'm a keeper I feel a loophole in
camp it's just amazing trust bygones
hazard of the cast I got all the great
so much shame to say that I trust it's
gonna have to grow on me cuz right now
something about that gun doesn't feel
right well what's the role you get
what's wrong strong no but it's it can
be the roller otherwise I don't know if
it's the recoil the way that gun fires
feels to me it is a different gun and
for me it's just throwing me off so it's
different it's different I love the gun
so I was like I gotta get on board
eventually but for me right it's under
the way that recoil is whether it's the
scope something about that gun feels off
to me and it's just one of those like I
go to fired and I'm like why do I feel
like I'm trying to shoot like you know
the wings off a fly I'm like shut out to
uh logical or dark shadow ride well I
think for me Brown was fun the first
couple of times now I'm okay I'm all
over it but I loved it when I had to go
get my subclass in actually started with
Chronos Chronos killed it all he said
the leading edge transits somebody just
saying let's see we got gambit Vanguard
strikes also patrols in the cream
Dreaming city I know somebody else said
ascendant challenges which honestly to
me
those have been a lot of fun they've
been stuck on the wanted bounties like
the same thing three weeks in a row
which is annoying but honestly those
have been cool cuz they've been a
different mechanic every time too
but I send a child to school but for me
personally talk to me
when I stepped into the shattered throne
that was at 3 manray baby
han mechanic the feel of it the scale
huge and then it just keeps going and
I'm like oh my god so shattered throne
for me it was like I mean watching the
rate is like it's amazing we did I did
churchy I did Kali and I got the more
guys and this team was not like just
didn't have it together so I mean I love
I love this I love those two encounters
to be honest first two I really love
those two incomes because I love the
idea I'm hiding that little hotel room
like I like
times I like a good straightforward DPS
phase sometimes you miss you know we
ain't gotta always mechanic something
all the time
sometimes you just wanna get him in and
rough something up and I like that Cali
Aspen and the Sherrill cheat thing
because of the speed and the tension and
my music for whoa
so yeah that's up there too that's up
knitting yeah so I mean the rain for
sure but yeah I mean the shattered
thrown was what was never even something
I knew was coming and then when I
stepped it and I was like hey let's
check this out I've not really looked at
I was like oh my god yeah I know
something is out there a lower light
level can't get people to do it
cute lad as well you said if you don't
have folks do it get to a high left
level there is a triumph to solo that
thing now of course you guys know
eventually if it's not this coming week
which I still don't know if I'm gonna be
high enough at some point I'm gonna get
a guide for you guys to solo that thing
even if you can't solo all of it you
there are three drops from it and the
first encounter if you're high enough
level Oscar is like low level yes
because like once you get far enough in
there especially to see the ogor it's
about 580
so I mean it's not low level stuff five
seventy-five eighty you're gonna want to
be up there I think what we did it up
first thank 545 maybe 550 we did the
first encounter two and actually
probably did okay so but no that's even
try it solo because if you're patient
you work through it there's no time
limit there's no nothing step into that
place and it's so much fun it's just
it's I never saw it coming and it's like
an ascended challenge to like to the you
know to the 10th level it's so cool
that's but yeah shadow thrown his mind I
mean the raid I expected to see coming
but to be completely blown away by the
shadow throne had no idea so no the -
definitely that mm-hmm
one of my dogs is on walk because Enzo's
back to do it as wolf al I can hear my
back salute Saladin's
know I don't let you guys hear it hold
on the be here to rise upon DLC
the doors open now we'll see if he does
it again but yes so yeah so one night
fall with a hundred thousand score I
will work on that one some 600 power
level because I'm gonna need all the
point modifiers I can get on that one
but otherwise guys I think we're getting
close to two hours so I know he rambled
on for these last a little bit but
honestly for you guys in chat it's been
awesome this morning I know the more
people following both of us the better
if you guys are in my twitch chat right
now go over to youtube click on iron
Lords podcast hit subscribe I want you
guys to give me the necklace mom thank
you Lord send them over watch I
appreciate which do it right over there
like in like wise man all you guys like
I said in the chat when I open please
subscribe leave on says tremendous
content tremendous and great guides man
very very patient very stooped very
detailed if you're trying to do
something out I've been using them
myself bad it's a solo runs because a
lot of times what's happening for me is
I haven't I've been using you guys a lot
honest because a lot of times I don't
have a very limited time and I come on
destiny probably when I shouldn't be I'm
just so mad I got real-life stuff I got
to do something awful I'm playing
destiny and I'm like all right let me
try solo it's it's tough I mean that's
everybody has those moments where you're
like you not everybody's on it's just me
it's 4 o'clock in the morning I should
be sleeping when I'm home like not
everybody's always on and that's kind of
one of the reasons but yeah if you guys
want long-winded detailed things yeah
that's my way I'm not gonna be your
short succinct I'm gonna give you guys
that run through hopefully cover builds
but I try and do I try and go through as
much as I think that will help you guys
sometimes it may be long-winded but most
people who seem to jump in I get the few
down votes and honestly that's just one
of those that so is the internet but
most you guys appreciate them and if
there's ever anything I can do to
improve them believe me I read every
comment so yes definitely
leave one on there if there's anything I
can do to improve if you're like hey
shorten this up put it all on screen go
over real quick shut up and just people
just like
you know yeah so I mean thank you guys
for both but definitely share the love
between both of us get both of these two
sides if you got anybody looking for
just a gaming podcast if they like Xbox
in any way shape fashion or form it
doesn't have to be Xbox just gaming in
general all those guys over there in
King said it best we're all gamers we
love games and we have fun playing these
things so like fanboys aside like the
interviews they get some of the like the
information you've got from like Matt
piscatella from the NPD's and then
backup lawyers and I haven't got to the
one from which one oh the really
detailed digital guys oh you gotta get
digital digital found on that's like the
next one that's gonna be up on I've been
catching up on all my podcasts so that
like I mean I mean come on if you guys
don't know in the world of technical
stuff those are the guys who break down
like frame rates on games and how things
and they're like they're very very
technical guys it's like depends on your
wants absolutely so I mean there's some
awesome stuff on there definitely some
always good content that's prime but
yeah thank you guys all for both just
the growth on this we've had almost up
to like 20 viewers in my twitch chat for
this thing for me that's good awesome
really cool so the Cutie Lakhia chase
late he was like he's just in it that's
not like you said English wasn't his
first language so I'm actually curious
yeah Cronos just killing me with the
deleting edge transits though it's like
activity just across another one of
those off the list
trying to steal my little masterwork or
from spider everyday oh yeah I gotta log
in before I get off very cool halfway
across the ocean so yep I think that's
what we'll wrap it up guys as a land of
poke but thank you guys been an awesome
chat this morning we love doing this and
we love the more you guys chat the
better these are so thank you both on
both sides hug me oh you want to wrap
your side up first please subscribe to
both of our channels we've already said
that it's essent ly um yeah this Sunday
we will be on our podcast will return on
Tech Network you'll be live in the live
chat so make sure you are there no
guests this week we're keeping this
movie but we got a lot of great topics
maybe a cameo who your name will see
maybe get a cameo come in but early you
next week will have a very special one I
won't I'll break that next class when
they have a nice special one for fans of
a specific game so that should be cool
although specific game a way to give a
specific don't you love it don't you
love my detail but yeah we'll be on a
football Sunday the inner circle Network
11 a.m. that we will start and that is
the loss on every Sunday is the Lord's
Day we have a good time we'll talk about
what's going on the industry and all the
latest topics between Microsoft Sony
Nintendo it's fun coming allowed to have
some fun with us it's great and then
also we have extreme team guys
salud to some alda which I've seen in
the chat el boogie you knows who style
we're gonna do more things on the iron
ore podcast channel YouTube channel we
have an original content there also a
lot of interviews III we go to shows we
go to pax we do all these things and try
to give you guys exclusive content and
of course the greatest to main destiny
podcast you've ever heard of course
flashpoint in the building with YouTube
Kings o Lord parties solo nightfall
solo ascended challenge I don't I don't
even I still don't even know what to do
with the that is if you guys want to
know what he's talking about by the way
just go to trending click on gaming and
I'm like forward
whoa respect his name he's the only
problem with that little shout-out
especially is it's on the gaming page
that stuff is like 2 or 3 weeks old ones
from the 18th ones from the 25th is
deserved from the 28th we're not going
to be smirched a great name this is
monumental I've seen this man grow from
my first Guardian car and he's become
[Laughter]
you work very hard love what you're
doing it's really an honor to do this
show with you because we both two nuts
that love talking about not starting
this thing back in January like
dumbasses but you know
that's all right we made it this time we
never got a good room so remember as
little people when you make it big
no they're awesome so thank you guys
very much it's awesome I think we'll
wrap it up you guys will find this one
sometime over the weekend I'll schedule
it so Saturday May or Sunday if you want
to listen to it or share with a friend
if somebody who likes destiny just kind
of wants to know what's coming and what
has been going on let me know about it
so I'm still working on the audio piece
that will be eventual trust me but other
than that guys thank you very very much
for me you guys know where to find me
it's twitch Twitter YouTube it's ebon
chess everywhere subscribe follow and
send the love to both of these places we
got out here iron Lords podcast ebon
tests thank you guys and I think that's
will wrap it up I have a good one see
you guys soon awesome chats have a
goodies